hello and welcome to this video playing
L marmalade that's Elma Megara mauve
yeah from Azerbaijan so we got some
English opening you can either a
transpose too many things think he you
place this kind of thing yeah he bears a
tirage and semi tirage these kind of
openings um cheek now it's probably not
a big difference always had issues with
that opening I never studied it that's
it that gets to be problematic against
someone like him already knows what's
going on can I do something else maybe
like this is that a move why it looks a
bit passive and at the end I'm still
going to that main line now yeah I only
know that well it's not so great i mean
not so great this is wrong it just said
i have no really great idea how it works
so maybe bring the night over to d3
that's an idea that i have seen in this
kind of position usually after the point
is coming to deform maybe this is a bit
early now
the tarish and cemetery something that I
absolutely should study at one point
against experts like like him I I get
into trouble I tend to get into trouble
and all I don't by the way not experts
in terms of that sometimes this is some
experts to describe flying strength I
mean I mean this is not when is very
strong GM I'm saying like people who
know the opening really well okay well
here 95 is the idea you don't need to be
very knowledgeable to see that mm-hmm
Bishop f4 i'm just going to into e7
maybe I also b4 b5 as an idea that also
supports a possible 95
okay well just take that thought that
possibly the be porn is a is an issue
here CMC does not not only does not
agree with that that assessment okay
let's check the night light c4 I think I
can probably just take a look takes pawn
takes we need seven Bishop d7 Bishop d7
and the sea pawn my c pawn gets
tremendously strong okay so i'm coming
20 from the one so don't need to i mean
i can use that now may be here for a
possible rook be one attacking that b7
pond and I'm keeping an eye on e5 mmm
one idea is also that Bishop d6 is
cutting the cover of the d5 pawn so it's
not so easy for him to keep b7 and d5
well then well defended
not easy firm to play
just keeping pressure on threatening
Bishop t6 now and then taking g5 yeah
this is what I expected him to play for
a while but he didn't do that yet I
think I still think this is good
natural have played by 56 first I was a
stupid mistake very stupid mistake
actually I had fantastic position if I
just play Bishop t6 before that and here
i mean it's may be good but it's far
less far less one-sided some some more
tricks and things going on here now form
for him ok this is to threaten look
tasty form mostly well and i'm grabbing
a pond that's what's not bad to take the
porn and it's not reacting to my threat
that's surprising or is there a big
point I don't see it I have no idea
queena 30 what's the idea if you must
clean your 30 go book d6 for the pin
g5 I can actually just take so there is
no big need them just would like to get
rid of this Queen that would be would be
really nice to get rid of it taking a
six no I just look 27 maybe I mean the
pin is still on yeah maybe just route 27
and cover just a tech g7 what is he
doing them
now it's okay you can only try some
swindles they don't see anything great
home
this is covered right what is the point
he wants to go queen no one's to go look
on the second book on the second rank is
this idea
time warning
going to a forum in case of rugby too
and I'm still threatening to take on g7
and 95 I take the rook so I don't see
him don't see a move a real good one
yeah now this form for a counter-attack
home rogue d8 would be the
counter-attack black forfeits on time
ride out sometime now it's a position is
also complete complete disaster mmm that
looked ok I mean I still don't feel very
good about my first couple of opening
moves I know that this is kind of right
but whenever of it they get on the
border I think okay I mean why isn't
that why isn't that great I mean why is
that great for white and it's supposed
to be better for what but um well
doesn't convince me so much this is a to
pick a regrouping and now night c5 is on
yeah I think before as a decent move
Knight c5 is an idea b5 as an idea so he
has to react somehow and now I put it
here and today well okay maybe he has to
take but after that i'm definitely in
good shape for bishop to d6 and covering
p8 yeah it's a good move i think i had
to go back and not proof by Queen a
little bit so 95 wasn't so successful I
think our d 5 is under pressure and III
around the addy form is probably not so
great i don't know i mean the engine is
on +1 that basically says i have a big
advantage after that it gives me a wind
actually that i'm winning stuff yeah and
here bishop t6 what seems to be even
stronger and but i don't think this is
bad right I at least I hope yeah it's
also winning so winning I doesn't have
anything right this is important here
that this is no good i thought queen bee
three a tener que creen b3 is right and
winning that pond so if that point is
going no danger now
age 5 yeah okay took here which he may
be did not see or didn't I know and I
look Ruby several rooty 657 immediately
house that was strong but at this this
queenston seven would be to and create a
for to end it yeah and here you for free
in on time yeah okay that was a really
good game the engine didn't give me not
even in Akron I mean only stuff like
plus four instead of plus 5 and this is
something that you can easily live with
seemed seemed like a good game he had
thought mistake there may be at this age
five and when he was in bad shape but
maybe he really didn't see you text you
form position was most kind of critical
already okay well thanks for watching